everybody's Dwayne Johnson here at the
Hobbes and Shaw junket here in beautiful
Hawaii I'd love to say hello to my good
friend Idris Elba who is the second
sexiest man alive Chase is a decent
driver Wayne Duane I'm not sure Wayne
Wayne hey gentlemen I'm at the Shell bar
coming live from London as you can see
on the green screen and this is an idiom
abroad and unlucky Idris has to be there
in London Kentucky Warfel Kentucky
waterfall I have no understanding what
that means I imagine it could mean a
bargain bucket Kentucky fall in a hole
over your head and he just sort of like
okay and it actually means Kentucky
waterfall actually means meaning it is a
money a mullet and it's a lovely picture
of no explanation a popular hairstyle
that was associated with the state of
Kentucky
give me a tinkle on the blower here's
the thing with this I know this for sure
that has to do with masturbation because
I have said this many a nights as I've
drink tequila and when I do say this it
always leads to make a baby
swipe give me a phone call I call
Shotgun I call Shotgun
this is quite apt fast and furious film
I call Shotgun means you're gonna
someone's driving and you're gonna sit
right next to it was called I call
Shotgun I don't know why they say that I
call some and I'm got a clue so I'm
about to find out right now and the
meaning is I ride passenger seat and the
explanation is refers to the armed guard
who sat next to the steak
fantastic who would I most want to go on
a road trip with chases a decent driver
Wayne Duane I'm not sure Wayne Wayne uh
yeah you don't want me to sit shotgun
you need me I'm shotgun you want me on
shotgun
you don't want Jason Statham on shotgun
you want the kid he's a big lad you sit
next to him you squashed up next to this
you next to the window so go kick his
ass out of the car so quick I think
you're so smart we get [ __ ] answers
Wayne did you know that no not a [ __ ]
criminal sure when I'm on set he's
number two now you like that [ __ ] he's
thrown a wobbly oh I know this no to
become very angry or upset I mean some
what if Jason Statham is masturbating
then that would a poopoo platter as
poopoo as in pu pu for those of you in
dirty minds i have no idea what a poopoo
platter ease if I'm gonna guess I
imagine it's a a plethora of mistakes
you know you drain a right poopoo
platter of that how I reviewed it and
the meaning in actuality is a tray of
Hawaiian food hmm
consistent of an assortment of small
meat and seafood appetizers explanation
derived from the Hawaiian word which
means a type on corners there you go
I'll have some food please thank you
very much I got completely Trollied last
night as to me and I I got drunk last
night I got it right you know I got it
right because I cheated I started it was
most likely to forget lines like out of
the three of us I don't forget lines
this is led Bible and this is a shiny Oh
easy that would be Jason saving Jason he
forgets lines and Duane just makes them
up it hit the meat and two veg so
there's a few ways we could go with this
maybe this has to do with some food
maybe with like a meat pie and a veggie
pie or something like that and oh wow it
hit me in the private parts and here is
the last one ladies and gentlemen and I
plead the fifth everyone says that I
plead the fifth it means I ain't saying
[ __ ] all right I plead the fifth also I
imagine it comes from the 8th amendment
which is a right to silence in American
law and the meaning is the fusilade so a
question that could embarrass or
incriminate yourself like I said I own
says [ __ ] oh no we've run out of bog
roll we've run out of toilet paper
Oh Duane it citrus how are you pal you
were amazing in the movie and so was the
other fella what's his name again
incredible I really enjoyed myself as
well actually lovely boy
my friend thank you brother and it was
wonderful and I just tried my best with
what I got
[Music]